hey this is pressed all Walker and
you're watching mind your decisions
here's a very fun number puzzle you
start out with three identical copies of
each number and you need to make it
equal to six the puzzle is to make each
equation true using common mathematical
operations there are two rules first
you cannot introduce any new digits so
for example the operation of cube root
would not be allowed because it involves
the digit 3 the second rule is you must
have the result equal to 6 you cannot
use the not equal symbol I think Tyler
Senko for first suggesting me this
problem and I think kayo sir kara from
Brazil for also suggesting it I also
want to present a note my videos will
make you so smart that even difficult
problems like this will become easy to
you in videos like this you'll see
people asking for harder problems and
it's the best proof that these videos
are teaching math to people around the
world so can you figure it out give this
puzzle a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so how
can we solve this puzzle I'll mention
that some of the equations have multiple
answers due to time constraints and only
going to present some of the solutions
and you may have found another creative
method to solve one of the equations let
everyone know your answer in the
comments
we'll start solving these by going from
some of the more straightforward and
easy ones to then some of the more
involved in harder problems let's start
out with 2 2 - 2 equals 6 we can solve
this by using the equation 2 plus 2 plus
2 is equal to 6 so we've already figured
out 1 now 6 6 6 is also similar we can
take 6 plus 6 minus 6 to get to 6
or we can also do 6 times 6 over 6 is
equal to 6 for our aggregation of
solutions let's just go with the first
equation now let's solve 7 7 7 equals 6
we can do this as 7 minus 7 over 7 is
equal to 6 we get a very similar
solution for 555 we can take 5 plus 5
over 5 is equal to 6 so we're making
good progress now let's solve 3 3 3 is
equal to 6 one way to solve this is 3
times 3 minus 3 is equal to 6 but there
are actually several more solutions for
this another one is 3 factorial plus 3
minus 3 is equal to 6 we can also do 3
factorial times 3 over 3 is equal to 6
or we can do something like the square
root of the quantity 3 times 3 and then
we can add 3 and that's also equal to 6
so for presentation purposes I'll just
take 3 times 3 minus 3 is equal to 6 now
let's solve 9 9 9 is equal to 6
well one trick we can use is let's take
the square root of each of these 9s
here's a handy mathematicians trick
since the square root of 9 is equal to 3
we have reduced the problem to solving 3
3 3 is equal to 6 and this problem has
previously been solved so any of our
solutions for 3 through 3 is equal to 6
will also apply to this 9 9 9 once we've
applied the square root to each of the
9s so we could solve this as the square
root of 9 times the square root of 9
minus the square root of 9 that's equal
to 6 or we take the quantity the square
root of 9 factorial plus the square root
of 9 minus the square root of 9 is equal
to 6 or we have some other solutions
like the square root of 9 factorial
times 9 over 9 is equal to 6 or the
quantity square root of 9 times the
square root of 9
/ the square root of nine we take the
whole thing and the factorial of that
and that is also equal to six for
presentation purposes I'll just take
this first equation now let's go to four
four four is equal to six
well once again we can take the square
root of each of these numbers again we
have our handy trick since the square
root of four is equal to we have reduced
the problem to two two two is equal to 6
and that's previously been solved for
example we can take the sum of these
numbers and that'll be equal to 6 but if
you don't want to do that you can also
do the quantity 4 minus 4 over 4 and we
take the factorial of that quantity we
can also do the square root of 4 plus 4
over 4 we take that entire quantity and
then take the factorial of that and
that's also equal to 6 so for
presentation purposes let's just take
this first equation now let's solve 10
10 10 is equal to 6 let's do this in
steps we'll do 10 minus 10 over 10 and
at this point our result is equal to 9
well now take the square root of this to
get to a result of 3 then we will take
the factorial so that's how we can get
10 10 10 to equal 6
now what about 1 1 1 well notice if we
add the three numbers we get 2/3 and
then we'll take the factorial and that's
equal to 6 so now how do we solve 0 0 0
is equal to 6 well first we'll take the
factorial of each of these numbers we
again use a mathematicians trick since 0
factorial is equal to 1 we have reduced
the problem to 1 1 1 is equal to 6 which
has previously been solved so we add up
these numbers and then we take the
factorial of the sum and that will be
equal to 6 finally how do we solve 8 8 8
is equal to 6
many people consider this to be the
hardest of all of these equations
so we'll work in steps we'll take eight
plus eight and that's equal to sixteen
we'll take the square root of that and
the square root of 16 is equal to four
we then take the square root of the
square root of that so the square root
of the square root of sixteen will be
equal to two
now we take eight minus two and that's
equal to six
so that's one way to solve this but
another way that you could solve this is
you could take eight plus eight over
eight and that'll be equal to nine we
then take the square root of nine which
will be equal to three and then we take
the factorial of 3 and that's equal to
six
so that's it we figured out how to get
six in each of these equations did you
figure it out thanks for watching these
math videos inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they
already have over a hundred million
views but the math meanies never praise
them and spread their negativity let's
be extra positive to cancel them out
please help by subscribing for free to
get the newest videos watching and
sharing all of mind your decisions
videos and you can email me a puzzle or
math topic at presh and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can
support me on patreon to earn exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support